who's going to give you your 12th
grandchild who do you think oh wow 12th
grandchild
um
kylie jenner gave birth to her son on
february 2nd but grandma kris jenner is
already thinking about who's next
family's family on thursday the momager
stopped by the ellen degeneres show just
give us a cocktail and we'll be going
like this for hours chris kicks things
off by gushing over kylie's baby boy
named wolf
congratulations you're another a grad
your 11th grandchild my 11th grandfather
and he's so cute
then ellen surprises chris with a family
themed pop quiz
i'm going to give you a quiz because i
think this is incredible okay name all
of your uh grandkids okay mason penelope
reign
north saint chicago sam
uh stormy
wolf um hold on dream
um
how many is that you're missing one help
me i'm missing one uh-huh i said dream
um true yes oh true i love you so much
yes
yeah
sure she needed a little lifesaver there
but chris's intelligence never fails to
impress
case in point check out how she
responded to this
who's going to give you your 12th
grandchild who do you think oh wow
twelfth grandchild
um hmm
well i think it would be nice if it was
kendall
right do you think she's the only one
who hasn't had a baby does she want to
have a baby
i think she would eventually love to
have a baby yeah eventually yeah listen
up kenny you've been put on alert oh my
god just be cool it's fine
unless ellen's tongue-in-cheek
prediction comes true she's not going to
be the 12th though i think there's gonna
be one before she's gonna have one
really uh-huh who do you think it's
gonna be i know who it is you do oh are
they already pregnant and i don't know
about it just tell me
please tell me like i know something
hopefully the family's upcoming hulu
series will help us pun intended keep up
you have no idea what's coming
the new show it's called the kardashians
and according to this sneak peek seems
like the cameras were rolling for some
big moments
are you ready the kardashians
so what can we expect to see they're
here now in the back shooting with us
and we're so happy to be you know up and
rolling again chloe shared her
excitement with ellen in september and
that same month kim told the talk show
host there's some long overdue romance
updates whether it's like you know this
relationship or courtney's relationship
or whoever's it's like people have had
this like free time off and
had these beautiful
new relationships blossom and it's gonna
be really fun and interesting to see
filming dynamics and us back together
and i'm excited but the big question
leading up to the series premiere on
april 14th will we see kim's new beau
pete davidson it's a different
experience for sure
we'll keep a lookout but until the
series officially kicks off et is
learning new details about their
relationship specifically the snl star's
commitment to spending time with the
family a source tells e.t quote kim and
pete have gotten even closer in the last
few weeks pete has been going out of his
way to connect more with kim's family in
his own subtle ways he wants to show
them who he really is and have the
family get to know him better